All right,
we're doing a panel today and joining me
is old,
Grizzled Rubin Report Veteran and author
of heavens on Earth,
Michael Shermer and new returning champ.
I'm giving you a returning champ.
Read before you've even sat down here
once author of the new book,
political tribes,
Amy Chu,
and how are you?
Great.
Thanks for having me.
Yeah,
well thank you guys for coming in.
And Michael,
you set this up so I'm going to not let
you speak for just a moment.
I know you said up,
you said the three of us should sit down
and talk about a whole slew of issues,
but amy,
just so my audience can get to know you
a little bit since they know a lot about
Michael already.
Just give me a two minute synopsis of
who you are before we talk about the
book and why.
Okay.
Um,
well,
I'm a Yale law professor.
Um,
I,
I'm principally by about foreign policy
and democracy and ethnic conflict.
Um,
mostly developing countries.
and I teach at Yale Law School in 2011.
Something crazy happened to me.
Uh,
and that is,
I wrote in three months a memoir that I
thought was going to be really funny and
it was called battle hymn of the tiger
mother and the world exploded.
I created an international firestorm.
Everybody hated me.
I got death threats.
It was sort of just at the beginning of
people going bananas on twitter to
exactly.
And I didn't have those tools.
I had no social media tools.
I wasn't on facebook and I was just
caught off guard and I became known as
the notorious Tiger mother.
And so in some ways this,
um,
this new book is,
I,
I got sick of only being known as the
tiger moth.
I was on a TV show talking about
Ukrainian nationalism,
which I actually,
I know about nationalism,
I've written about it.
And afterwards I saw the twitter feed
and they were like,
why does this woman that's tiger woman
thinks that she can talk about
nationalism?
So like I did have a career before he
goes,
that's it,
you know,
I've lost control of the situation.
So in a way the new book goes back to
what I,
what I actually know a little bit about.
Well,
I just want to go on the record as
saying that as I am sitting next to the
tiger mom,
I feel an undue pressure to do this show
correctly.
Normally I can phone it in when I assure
him here,
but I feel a little extra credit.
David Book is actually about my younger
daughter rebelling.
It's a huge book about.
It's a rebellion but you'd like it
people.
The whole book is so wildly
misunderstood,
but it's.
It's been.
It's been fun.
Yeah.
You do want to talk a little bit about
some tiger mom stuff towards the end
because I think there's some interesting
things happening right now that we all
kind of need a little bit more of that
perhaps then the outrage machine thought
a couple of years ago,
but Michael,
why did you think that this would be a
good group to sit down together when he
sent me that email now?
Well,
because the book kind of political
tribes kind of set me back a little bit
in the sense that I've kind of had this
lifelong mission of spreading science
and reasoning,
critical thinking,
and then after I'm reading
pinker's book,
the better angels that inspired me to
write the moral arc and and kind of go
into this other direction of spreading,
not just science reasoning,
critical thinking,
but liberal democracy,
market capitalism and other social tools
that can be measured in the same way
that scientific things can be measured.
And one of the things that I like about
Steve's work is that he as a social
scientist tries to tease out what are
the causal variables that are
influencing people to do this or that,
you know,
can we tilt the incentives to get people
to be less violent by doing this?
Rather than that?
Exactly.
Like any scientist would.
So and so this idea,
and I'd read all this literature about
spreading democracy is a good thing and
spreading capitalism is a good thing.
And,
and,
and so,
but as you show him political tribes,
it's not quite as simple as I like to
think in my head,
if we could just go to all these places
around the world and bringing liberal
democracy,
bring a market,
capitalism freedom and prosperity,
you will prosper.
And it's quite.
We'll have this global community,
which is where I'd like to go.
I mean,
at some point we're going to be a
multiplanetary species.
We can't be fighting these little tribal
battles on Mars or,
or,
but actually I think we might end up
doing that if you're right,
that in fact these tribal tendencies are
pretty deep,
right?
I like these things too.
I love democracy and liberalism at
capital,
these enlightenment principles,
um,
but there's sort of no natural reason
that they should have ethnically neutral
implications,
consequences.
So democracy,
you know,
at some day,
uh,
if you had a global democracy,
but what,
it makes perfect sense that democracy is
going to empower the majority group,
the one with the bigger numbers.
That's just,
that's just a number that's very
scientific actually.
Um,
but similarly markets,
this is when I coined the term market
dominant minority in 2003.
Um,
we all started in different places.
So just free market capitalism,
even though it's fair in many ways by
equal,
you could argue that or we can have a
huge debate,
but there's no real logical reason that
at any given point in a given society
that though that free markets will
benefit all ethnic or racial or all
class are all religious groups equally.
So once you acknowledge that you,
like,
you have these transition questions.
So I thought maybe we should then with
that in mind,
start with something that's sort of
happening right now that might help
people frame a little bit of what all
three of our political positions are.
Because you,
I know we've,
I think the first time I had you on you,
at one point you had said you're a
libertarian.
I think you've also kind of said you're
a classical liberal.
Then you've kind of said enough with the
labels altogether.
I consider myself a classical liberal
tee shirt on you.
I've seen you,
I've seen you in the classical liberal
tee shirt.
That's right.
Of course everyone knows that I consider
myself a classical liberal,
but I definitely like a lot of the ideas
of libertarianism and I'm always sort of
more drawn to that.
If we were to put a label on just to
start
before I get into the specific issue,
I'm definitely not a classical liberal
and um,
I love classical liberals.
But,
um,
I think that one of the things I pointed
out in my book is that a lot of people
are tribal who don't think they are.
Right?
So if he liberal cosmopolitans
enlightenment people,
you think of yourself as the opposite of
pride because that was,
came out of the alignment on anti
religious warfare.
And,
but what I'm saying is where we are now
in America or even the world,
these,
it be a liberal.
Cosmopolitan is actually a pretty hard
trying to get into my.
First of all,
you were very judgey tribe and you
probably met a lot of different kinds of
people to be so cosmopolitan.
Um,
you know,
I was very struck and shamed myself.
I'd have a student,
I'm poor white person from the south who
had never been on a plane,
uh,
and that was actually kind of startling
because we,
the first question some professor was
asking,
so I think that I'm,
I like writing about tribalism because
I'm very aware of its effects,
you know,
I'm the child of immigrant parents,
but I'm very proud of my ethnic
identity.
Um,
but I also love this idea of America as
this umbrella,
um,
uh,
identity,
so that it's a complicated answer,
right?
Because I guess as a real,
you know,
real liberals don't have an account of
why even have the nation state that's
how far you want to go down.
Right?
So patriotism and all this stuff.
And My,
presumably that's,
that's,
that's at best a transitional thing for
you,
right?
Well,
that's where I don't go so far.
It depends how far you want to go down
the road of freedom depending on how you
find me a classical liberal ideas.
There is some utility in the state.
We just have to figure out what that is.
And I would want it to be the lightest
touch possible.
But just to answer it in one,
what I really am as I am somebody that
loves about America,
that it's,
uh,
it's,
and it's very unique that this is a
country that at once has a very strong
collective national identity or at least
did we can get to that and secondly
allows individual subgroup or tribal
identities to flourish.
Like you can be an Irish American or I'm
Korean American,
um,
or I make classic liberal and possibly
be very patriotic at the same time.
I think that's a very unique thing about
this country and that we're in danger of
losing that kind of magic formula.
Possibly.
So I think you just described the
melting pot,
right?
I mean,
isn't that the secret sauce?
Well,
I melting pot suggests that everybody
loses their identity like.
And I think that happened very
successfully with a lot of the northern
European immigrants,
but we've never really been a great
melting pot.
Like if you take the African American
population,
there've been many discrete groups that
never melted into that pot.
So I think part of it is a melting pot.
Some assimilation for sure,
but I think this common identity thing
can,
can coexist with a lot of different
kinds of diversity.
Some might be closer to the Canadian
kind of mosaic thing.
Um,
but I do really believe that you need
this connective tissue telling
everybody.
So I guess it depends what analogy,
like whether it's melting pot or mosaic
or,
but we've basically done
multiculturalism better than pretty much
everybody else.
Do you mean
that's where you say,
yeah.
So the balance here is how can I
maintain that,
my,
my local group identity,
which is easy to do because I identify
with people that look like me or live
near me or whatever.
That's totally natural and still respect
others because there's some umbrella.
And there previously when I was younger,
I would have thought,
well,
we don't need a government government.
You know,
this can happen just from the bottom up.
I've become a little more cynical about
human nature being dark,
uh,
in tribal,
in the sense that at some point you need
some kind of rules to govern,
say the marketplace to a certain extent,
at least steer it.
And that's why this,
this cake baking thing is I just go back
and forth.
It's like,
yes,
this,
she should be able to bake any cake he
wants.
We're not in the battle days when people
justified racism and know lunch counters
and buses segregated.
And at some point it took the federal
government saying we're sending the
troops in to set to integrate your
schools even though they're down there
in Alabama saying segregation forever.
At some point sometimes you,
you have to use force to get people at
least to start
to bring them around.
Right.
Okay.
So that is the one issue that I wanted
to do up top before we dive into the
book.
So you.
I tweeted out when when the decision was
made that basically my feeling is that
you have to offer.
We have the civil rights act of 1964.
I don't want to re litigate it.
You have to offer products to every
person regardless of race,
color,
creed and all of that stuff.
But that if there is a specific artistic
quality to it or a customization to it
and that happens to go against your
beliefs that you just don't have to do
it.
Whether I think that's abhorrent or not,
you just don't.
We wouldn't ask a,
a satanist wouldn't be allowed to walk
into a Muslim baker and say paint,
you know,
put my helmet on the cake.
No one in their right mind I think would
think that that's the government's job
to force the baker to do that.
There's always do when we teach this and
start spitting out the hypothetical.
That makes complete sense what you said.
But then they say,
I think Justice Kagan might have asked
how about a makeup artist,
right?
Can a make up artist refused to,
to,
to provide services to,
you know,
to gay people to,
you know.
So once you start pressing what counts
as being an artist for photography,
photography is a form of art or.
Right?
So that is the
interesting.
So,
right,
so go grocery store bagging right the
most.
So it sort of a mundane task.
We all go to the grocery to buy the
products that are there and they're,
all they have to do is put it in the bag
and walk out if a,
if a grocer,
we're saying we're not going to bag
groceries,
groceries for black people,
that,
that is actually in violation of the
1964 civil liberties act.
Um,
but the.
But the idea that we would force a
specific product.
You wouldn't want a,
a Jewish painter.
We shouldn't have to be forced to take
commissions from a Neo Nazi or they
tweeted out several other examples on
this,
but your fear basically where I think we
don't quite see eye to eye is that
eventually,
if we don't do some of this,
that things will devolve
that.
Is that fair to say?
I don't know.
You might be right that in,
in 2018,
it's not 1964,
so maybe we don't need such draconian
laws historically when you.
But also we needed those lows to reverse
Jim crow laws,
which don't exist in the battle days.
You needed to send the federal troops
into this to integrate the schools.
Maybe we don't need to do that now.
Maybe this one baker out of 100 will
refuse to bake a cake.
But as the,
as the justices pointed out,
okay,
we're gonna protect,
this guy's really just expressions.
But if it turns out that every other
baker refusing to bake cakes for blacks
and gays and so on,
then that we,
that we can't let that happen.
That may never happen.
Yeah.
What do you make of that?
Part of the decision that struck me is
like a really,
like kind of slimy way out of this.
Like,
well,
you're the law professor.
You know why they did that.
I think,
you know,
it is,
as everybody says,
it's an extremely narrow holding.
It's like a pundit just said that this
particular commission was displaying
hostility to religion in a way that
couldn't make them impartial.
So,
um,
I think that will be another decision.
I mean it's,
in a way it's just kind of kicked down,
right?
It just seemed like it had no teeth in
that regard.
Was like,
why didn't you make.
Yeah.
I don't think it was an unreasonable
holding,
but I do think they,
they just avoided the question.
Um,
you know,
what I,
I,
I think is what worries me right now is
the constitution was supposed to be the
vaccine that sort of what protected
against political tribalism and I know
we're going to get to that,
but what I see that's kind of dangerous
and dismaying and the twitter feed right
now is that,
um,
it's like tribalism as attacking of the
constitution to,
you know,
it's not just something that we disagree
with,
but it's like there's a lot of
demonization of the other side.
Look,
there are,
if you teach the law school,
and I'm not a con law professor,
that's not my area.
I teach contracts and you know,
international business transactions.
But one thing you know is there are hard
cases and this is a hard case,
right?
You will have print multiple principals
are different rights clashing or weird
facts.
And what would I think is almost more
scary is you see people on the two sides
right now.
It's like if you think that a baker
should be allowed to refuse to bake a
cake celebrating gay marriage,
then you're a bigot and homophobe.
Right,
right,
right.
But on the other side there,
no.
You know the it,
it's like you're on the other side.
If you are take the other view,
then you are declaring jihad on Judeo
Christian values and this is the is so
ratched up and it's not good.
I think the main takeaway is spend less
time on twitter.
People are normal.
Well that that actually is part of it
because if you talk to average people,
not not average.
People don't even like that phrase.
If you talked to the neighbor and
everyone else in real life,
they don't behave the way they behave on
twitter.
It seemingly has taken a hold of our
entire national discourse.
So let me ask you this then,
because I do think most of these things
become local.
If there was a baker that did not want
to to bake a cake for a for Chinese
people or a whatever it is,
how would you feel is the right thing to
do?
Well,
that's just a personal thing.
I would just go to a different bakery,
but that's what I wanted to.
I wanted to make it personal.
That's even saying that doesn't mean
that I would,
um,
disrespect somebody else that did it.
It's really just my approach to life,
you know,
like,
well,
I really wouldn't want that wedding
cake.
What is it that the only way really to
respect freedom,
I mean the freedoms that we have here is
in your decision to either do something
or not do something or,
or go to a business or not go to a
business or whatever.
I was like,
the only real way to broadly protect
freedom is that it's Kinda Shitty,
right?
It doesn't,
it doesn't feel great
and it could be,
we don't need the laws now because we
have social media.
People shun that Baker on social media
or,
and not go to that store or if that's
what you want,
you do give them your,
your business is that the market sort of
sorts it out.
That mismatch your point about the civil
rights and needing force initially,
like where do you get there?
How do we get these?
We didn't end slavery by by market
forces.
We took a walk and sometimes you allow a
lots of people to do this.
Can you get an regressive norm change?
It depends on what you think about human
nature.
I think I'm similar to you.
I believe my journal going back,
I mean,
well I would.
I always say I'm a world weary optimist
that it's the only way that I could do
this the way that I do it,
but I look,
I,
I just don't think.
I'm not calling for reversing,
but just to be very clear,
I'm not saying we should be litigated or
reverse the civil rights act,
but the idea that we need that in 2018
so that people aren't opening up white
only businesses or anti gay businesses
or bowling alleys that aren't for trans
people are giving you a couple other
good ones here.
You know what I mean?
Roller Skating rinks.
It's interesting.
Going to the political situation.
There are,
there are some differences in America
today because I studied American
history.
That's kind of what I've been looking at
for the last hundred years and because
of these big demographic changes that
we're having now,
so-called what with whites about to on
the verge of no longer being a majority
in this country,
that's about 15 years.
The numbers from 20,
44 to 2050.
And then there are debates about whether
that's the big had happened,
but most people can see that even in
Texas,
in California,
it's already happened.
And um,
again,
the study's kind of show,
I mean,
this is going to sound terrible,
but for most of this country's history,
it was dominated economically,
politically,
and culturally by a white majority.
And the result of that is lots of bad
things could happen,
but there's also a little room for
generosity and it's a little right now
with this demographic change about to
happen.
Um,
what I write in the book is that every
group feels threatened.
This is,
you know,
it's not just the minorities felt
threatened,
Whitesfeld threatened,
um,
Latinos,
Asians feel threatened,
you know,
with the me too movement.
Men feel threatened,
women feel threatened,
straighten it.
So,
and it's when people felt threatened
that they retreat into tribalism and get
more US versus them.
So on this Baker thing,
you know,
you just never know,
like we're,
we're at a funny moment right now with
are candidates running on like white
nationalist platforms in a way that
wasn't like in the last 50 years or
openly at least.
Right?
So,
okay.
so granting you that.
I guess what I would say then is that if
that's all true and we maybe are about
to get much more tribal and start seeing
more outward racism and the rest of it,
that perhaps even if we allowed those
businesses to exist,
that your answer is still the right one.
The answer of use social media,
use your influence,
use your dollars.
Don't live in a state or a town that is
supporting these things like that.
The experiment should still go on with
the least amount of government.
But I get why this is.
So
for example,
when you brought that up in the book
about everybody feels personally as an
atheist,
I'm always amazed when he's born again,
Christians go,
we are a persecuted minority in this
country.
It's like,
are you kidding me?
Nine out of 10 of you were around me.
You're the person that we really feel
that you are.
Well,
I live in La.
It's not so bad.
But when I travel it's like,
okay,
well I am really in the minority here,
but two,
two quick things on sometimes the need
for government for us,
like the burning of widows in India.
That was ended by the British
colonialists that said you're going to
stop doing this or else.
And they said,
but you have to respect our culture.
all right,
here's our culture.
If you burn women,
we build gallows and paying you.
So you go ahead and build your funeral
pyres and we're going to build our
gallows and we can respect each other's
goals.
And that put an end to it.
And then in Papa New Guinea,
jared diamond tells this story about,
you know,
rates of violence A.
I mean,
it was like a hundreds of times more
than the natural background,
but rates of violence even in the
sixties and no one liked the violence,
but it was just the result of these
little local tribes.
And finally the overall government,
when they got some power,
they said,
all right,
no more violence if you kill somebody at
a vengeance or whatever.
He took your pig and so whatever.
We're gonna put you in jail and we're
gonna lock you up and that's it.
And,
and,
but,
but most people were happy about this.
Jared said,
it was like,
thank God somebody came in,
the parent came in and said,
stop fighting.
Right?
And I guess I would say we don't live in
Papa New Guinea and you don't live in
British colonial India.
Maybe more of a local example would be
in sports,
like insightly.
My sport,
most cyclists don't want a dope,
but there's an escalating like the game
theory escalation thing where if you
think everybody else's dope and you got
to do it and what they really want is
somebody on top say,
okay,
no more doping and we're going to test
because they don't really want a dope,
but they feel they have to dope.
So you need some kind of structure.
So stop cheating stuff,
kill Ya.
We don't want to cheat,
but you know,
but so you've got to tilt the incentive
somehow,
and I hate to say it,
but sometimes that has to come from the
top down a little bit.
It's,
it's very interesting.
So right.
Your book is called political tribes
now.
As you know,
I'm a.
I'm a believer in the individual.
I think that the individual is the
answer to stop bigotry and prejudice and
all of those things because you won't
look at someone as the member of a group
and you owe black people think this or
Muslim people think or gay people think
this.
If you look at the individual will wait
until you know what they think.
So sell me on the value of tribes.
Actually,
I'm just,
the reality of
tribes grabbed reality.
I'm closer to it.
You think?
I think we all need a big dose of
individuals in this country right now.
I teach on the college campus and I,
you know,
uh,
that's what we're supposed to be famous
for.
White America is a bunch of Mavericks,
but all,
you know,
I don't think these things are
inconsistent.
I do say that human beings,
and this is not a me saying it first,
but human beings are just biologically
tribal.
We need to belong to groups.
Um,
there are very,
very few hermits.
There can be individualistic,
but there are not hermits,
even monks to orders,
they compete with each other.
Right?
So there's very few sort of jd
salinger's at the end in the forest,
many of those.
Right?
Right.
I bet that if there were a retreat for
those people,
they probably really get along and
tribalism doesn't have to be bad.
And in fact it can be consistent with a
lot of individualism in sports.
You were saying like,
you know how,
but that's a great example.
Can you imagine somebody telling you to
get stopped liking your favorite team?
But I'm the and family it can be very
tribal of what I'm writing about now is
when tribalism takes over our political
system and that is what is really
dangerous because a feature of the kind
of problems I'm talking about is you
just want to stick to your side no
matter what.
You actually take pleasure in seeing the
other side.
Failure to sticking it to them.
And by the way,
I experienced this all the time,
right?
Um,
if somebody hurts you,
it's just human nature.
Um,
but we are,
we have massive problems in this country
right now.
And as both of you have talked about,
we're at a point where we just can't
talk to each other.
You know,
Americans can't talk to each other
anytime anything happens,
whether it's a shooting or anything
like,
um,
the,
the case,
um,
I think even worse than I'm not,
you know,
you could say it's all Steve Pinker.
It makes a great case.
And I'm not saying that we're worse than
in every way in terms of violence,
but in terms of tribalism in the
political sphere,
I think this is an unusual moment.
And partly that is,
I think because of the demographic
change,
it's very dislocating.
Um,
and,
and so I anyway,
no will not to bring everything back to
social media,
but I'm still partly convinced that it's
not just,
I accept the changing demographics and I
trumpism and all of those things.
But I still think,
and I see this as I'm on tour with
Jordan Peterson now and I'm getting back
into stand up in a meeting people
across,
you know,
from all the diversity that the left
loves but across a true diverse set of
ideas to who they want answers.
And we're just not hearing from these
people.
I mean,
there's a reason that the things that
we're all doing are working.
It's because we're fighting the forces
of that.
So for that reason,
I'm an optimist and you know,
when I had you on the first time,
which seems like 18 lifetimes ago,
and we were talking about the moral arc.
I mean,
that really was what you were selling me
that thing.
I mean it's,
it's very similar to the pink or idea
that things are bending in a good way.
It's just harder to see it now perhaps.
Well,
and also because we set our standards
higher so that people say students in
the sixties would be outraged by the
Vietnam War.
Now they're outraged by Halloween
costumes
and that's actually good because it
shows you where were the smaller thing
that we're obsessed,
right?
It's awesome.
There's a correction.
I think that went too far.
I think that's a good example of
suggesting that what you are calling the
market.
I think we're seeing a correction right
now,
um,
that whatever people think about the
2016 election,
many,
many people including elites were
shocked and such.
There's a lot of new thinking and even
from the Halloween costume thing now,
I think it's,
I,
I feel,
I feel that there's a little bit you
can't tell immediately you're still
going to see the controversies,
but I think there's a shift.
Well,
I think that's what's interesting
because it seems to me that some of us
in this intellectual darkweb or whatever
you want to call us at this point,
we saw this for the last couple of years
of Matt's what drew people doesn't
match.
That's the confirmation for me that
there is something bigger
growing here in identity politics thing
is a problem because it feeds into the
tribes,
your chapters,
a chapter on the trump phenomenon going
through nascar and world wrestling,
entertainment and,
and,
and it's like,
I never really thought of those as
tribes,
but of course they are.
Yeah.
And I contrasted that and I can't
believe I didn't get in trouble,
you know,
I teach at a very liberal school.
I just wait,
you're on the Rubin report is going to
happen.
Well,
about the occupy movement,
which,
you know,
uh,
and again,
I supported a lot of my students.
I love my students.
I have to say I am,
I am,
I am an independent.
Um,
and a lot of them are doing great things
for justice.
So I even think,
you know,
social justice warrior is again too big
a term,
you know,
I think that's also the label,
but occupy is a movement that I say was
a movement ostensibly to help the poor
that included no members of the poor.
It was vastly up at an elite group,
highly educated,
all these postgrads.
Um,
and then,
and yes,
then I say,
you know,
actually a lot of the progressive elites
don't,
aren't aware.
In fact a lot of the working class white
working class or any working class are
actually very suspicious of a lot of the
activists that are supposedly trying to
help them.
So that was an irony.
And then I talk about so many of the
poorer,
including minorities belonging to the
Prosperity Gospel,
the irony there,
praying for money,
they want money,
they're not trying to occupy.
So.
So yeah,
that's part of the thing that a lot of
thesis that a lot of elites in this
country wanting to do well actually just
aren't,
are,
are very blind to the group identities
and tribal dynamics that matter most to,
to just people on the ground.
So to that point
was trump's greatest coup here that he
was able to take the white working class
mainly,
but,
but other groups do and break them out
of their tribalism or even if you,
even the Christian conservatives who
voted for him at record numbers,
I think,
and still his support with them is
through like 90 percent or something
crazy that it.
They didn't vote for him for tribal
reasons because he's actually not one of
them.
Right.
He was a rich New Yorker,
so it wasn't.
Yeah.
I think that he has done a into job.
Well,
I think he's done a brilliant job
portraying himself as a member of their
cultural tribe,
cultural tribe as,
as working white working class
Americans.
And I don't think it's all a show
because a lot of group identification is
aesthetic.
It's an aesthetic.
It's a matter of style and values.
And in terms of the way that president
trump dresses and stuffs themself on
Mcdonald's compared to what,
you know,
not Vegan,
it just looked donald and steaks and the
suits,
the world,
the NASCAR and worldwide wrestling.
Are these things that are right about
these or not?
I got,
there was a negative review that said,
oh,
this fringe phenomenon.
And I showed the numbers.
These are NASA phenomenon,
these are the Prosperity Gospel.
These are millions and millions of
trump's in the hall of fame were all
arrested.
And so in my circles,
you know,
every time he said something sexist or
racist,
everyone was like,
now he's gonna be out of the office.
Nope.
And that,
the point is that people,
actually,
a lot of Americans actually identify
with the way he talks and says something
wrong or maybe lies and gets in trouble
than he's called out,
that they should,
like,
this happens to me all the time.
That's how they feel.
They don't feel like.
So.
So I think that he,
he has established a,
a,
a cultural tribal connection even
though.
Yes,
he's is.
And that goes to the other thing.
I think a lot of elites,
um,
I've been doing some research into this.
The socialists include a lot of people
who attend our top universities.
Um,
there are a lot of,
um,
working class Americans have,
whether they're Latino or African
American white who actually,
um,
would love to hit it,
make it big,
would love to enrich,
to have a big building and have a nice
car.
So there's a lot of irony in end in who
was championing what and it's actually
very,
very fascinating.
Yeah.
So it's just tribalism,
tribalism of a different sort.
I suppose.
So it's like all these rappers years ago
were rapping about trump because they
liked all of the gold and the blaming
and the branding and all
that's tapped into lots of different
strands.
Of course there was a racial thing that
he was able to tap into to,
but there was a lot of stuff there.
Wait,
I want to just slightly jump back to
this,
to this liberal tribe that thinks that
it's not a try because that seems to be
the group that I'm sort of most
personally frustrated with.
I go after you get a lot.
Well,
I guess so that probably has a lot to do
with it.
I'm not denying it,
but just accusing you of being in a
tribe and they're not in a tribe,
but that's not true.
So I guess that's what's driving me
crazy about this is that they constantly
are telling you,
you know,
that I'm totally talking about the New
York Times elite sort of.
I lived on the upper west for 15 years,
so I like a lot of these people
personally,
individually of course,
but that set of people that think that
everyone else is this thing and that
they are actually the ones who have
saucy while drinking the New York Times.
I,
I really do think that all of us are
tribal and that is definitely a tribe a.
and it's even by like,
if you take like anthropological or
social scientists definitions,
you know,
in terms of what you eat and your values
and your self perception and you know,
people vacation all the same places.
Um,
no,
it's,
it's definitely a tribe.
And you know,
I,
and I'm,
a lot of them are.
My friends are in that tribe and it's
very,
it just because it's one thing I say is
a lot of progressivism is actually,
it could also be doing great things,
but it is also really fun.
It's an identity formation,
you know,
people go,
like,
occupy was a very,
um,
it gave them some solidarity.
It was a fun feeling of them.
A lot of the marches.
I think people are going to get a lot of
the politics while,
because they keep measuring the size of
the crowds everywhere,
the size of the protest.
And I think that's,
I don't know,
I think people have to watch out because
that's,
I think if you just look at the size of
the crowd,
you're like,
oh my gosh,
I see what the is going.
But maybe those are areas where the
whole.
I don't know.
So,
so when you were reading Amy's book as
someone that's sort of tracked moral
progress through time,
um,
do you think there is a right amount of
tribalism that allows us to be the best
we can is as people in society?
Well,
I your epilogue talks about how to break
through some of that,
which I liked because there's a lot of
social psych there.
How can we quit thinking of each other
in that way?
But the other bigger issue on the spread
of market capitalism say that you
identified these a market,
dominant minorities.
I had no idea this was happening in
Vietnam and I just binge watched Ken
Burns's,
you know,
18 hours of the Vietnam war and I,
I don't remember anything about the 10
percent of the population over 90
percent of the
companies.
As relates to your point about this is
something funny.
I keep getting in trouble for every book
that I've written about the taboo for
reasons that I think are silly.
I don't think they should be terribly.
So I coined this term of 2003 a market
dominant minorities and it refers to
small,
usually ethnic minorities like the three
percent Chinese in Indonesia.
Just three percent ethnic Chinese who
control 70 percent of the economy.
Now what I wrote that I think the
instant us liberal progressive
responses.
Wait,
how could she say that?
It's like she's got to be stereotyping.
She's,
but I just documented it
even though it can also be argued that
that's a positive stereotype because
it's through work and education and all
sorts of questions.
So comfortable with any group,
acid make generalizations.
Um,
and I was saying,
look,
if we're going to ever solve these
problems.
So it also,
when I even say whites in South Africa
about 14 percent controlling,
you know,
80 percent of the best land.
So even the reasons for being a market
dominant minority can vary.
Sometimes it can be a history of
colonialism or apartheid.
So,
so nobody celebrating it necessarily,
although groups like the Chinese or the
Indians or the Lebanese are harder to
explain because they were non
colonizers.
So yes,
this is a phenomenon that fits,
um,
it's,
it,
it coexists in a complicated way with
these enlightenment forces.
Um,
because you want would be nice if,
if,
if markets just just benefited all
ethnic ethnicities,
Ito.
But what,
what does this tell you about how we
treat victimhood?
Really?
So the example I can use,
we do,
and you just mentioned this about the
three percent Chinese.
It's like when,
I'm sure you guys saw this a couple
months ago when this documentary came
out about Apu from the simpsons.
Yes.
And I saw night 90 percent of what I saw
online.
And again,
it's just what you're reading online was
actually no,
he was a good character.
He's beloved by everybody.
He's actually the hardest working guy in
the town.
He's one of homer's good friends.
They did an episode on on immigration
because of him,
you know,
he's a Vegan at all.
All of these wonderful things.
Indian Americans I think are the number
one socioeconomic group in the country
are pretty damn close to it.
I think their average median incomes,
six figures or it's a great measure of
success in all of these things.
And yet I saw this sliver of the people
that I'm frustrated with,
this sort of elite,
lefty,
whatever you want to call them,
progressive's demanding that this victim
hood should exist.
And that to me is the root of.
So much of our
tribal problems are about forgetting
your successes.
Yeah.
I,
um,
well,
first of all,
I just,
again,
just personally I understand where the
people are coming from,
but personally I,
I,
I just don't like the victim put thing.
I think it's also psychologically very
difficult waiting and you get this
oppression Olympics where you're,
you know,
your who can be lower,
you have more problems.
Um,
but on this,
without getting,
because I have had a lot of south Asian
friends say that they were very upset
about it.
To my surprise,
I try to understand and I wonder if
there's a big generational thing,
which is partly,
it feels bad,
but it partly what makes America great.
Um,
you know,
my dad,
when I was young,
my dad was immigrant and get a Chinese
accent and I would see him being what
you might call discriminated against
somebody,
like whatever.
And I would feel so bad.
I'd be like this eight year old kid and
just feels so shameful and so angry and
think my dad didn't even notice,
you know?
And then later had mentioned to my dad
and he's like,
this is such a great country.
She's thinking,
I came from,
I came from and I'm going to rise and,
and,
and he just made it the American dream.
But,
um,
so I,
I often in,
you know,
as an older person now I see very
generationally,
I think I,
I bet if you asked an older generation
of,
uh,
of South Asia,
it's about that I wonder if you might
not get a difference,
whereas you get the children or
grandchildren of those immigrants and
they're in a very different mentality,
educated in our campuses,
much worse than you know.
Uh,
so that's,
that's really what you're talking about
when you talk about the Halloween
costumes,
right?
That the arc here has meant so much that
you can actually put aside all of the
successes and then to just be upset by a
cartoon character.
So this is,
again,
it's a net good.
I think it's important to that good,
but,
but it's fine tuning younger people's
intuitions to go toward smaller and
smaller,
uh,
assaults on their ego or dignity or
whatever that they then elevate into
these massive,
like this is the equivalent of slavery,
rapey and the environment is the
equivalent of rape or whatever,
you know,
it's just elevating the,
these words in things that they can get
worked up about because we do have a,
a moral module or network or whatever in
our brain that we get worked up over
things and whether,
if it's the Vietnam war,
okay,
but now it's the Halloween costume,
but it's the same emotions that are
still being driven.
And that's another problem with these
tribalism,
you know,
maybe the moral arc.
Maybe again,
I'm an optimist too.
Um,
and I think something is changing after
2016.
I have many.
I quote this guy,
Giovanni,
extremely progressive student,
um,
Latin American parents from Mexico lived
in a trailer park and he saying,
I think we went to bar week stop on this
Halloween costume.
The line he uses is that crying wolf too
much.
Right?
So that when you get serious and um,
so,
so I actually think there's some
correction,
not everybody,
right?
There's still things that um,
are just,
just a waste of time,
you know,
we have serious,
serious problems and um,
but,
uh,
but I think there is some sense even
even among this group saying,
you know,
maybe this is not the best thing to
focus on.
Well,
what do you guys make of the fact that
this seems to be global right now?
That I know that because of technology,
that this movement,
whatever,
whatever's happening here now where so
many people are waking up to the
overcorrection or whatever you want to
call it,
that the amount of email that I get from
people that are seeing this in India is
what I'm getting from people that are
seeing this in Canada.
That,
that tells you something really
interesting happening despite the
differences in the political histories.
And,
and,
uh,
you know,
the political establishment of those.
It could be a selective focus because of
social media and realtime covering of
these incidences.
I do wonder to what extent the problem
really exists on college campuses of the
this campus craziness like Chapman
University where I'm at,
I'd never seen anything like this and,
and,
and most of the time when I travel and
give talks at colleges,
you never see anything.
It's just people just students are
hunkered down doing their thing.
I got to bring you to University of New
Hampshire next time,
changed your opinion on that pretty
quick.
They shaking or something that's made,
but it could be that the minority,
it's a minority,
but they're loud and they're instantly
covered now.
So it seems like Tucker Carlson in his
weekly campus craziness.
It's like if I walked on campus,
I wanted to see riots going,
well,
no,
you don't hardly ever see anything.
So there's this idea of pluralistic
ignorance or the spiral of silence where
a minority can take over.
Toxic ideology can take over a country
like Germany in the 19 thirties were
probably.
Most Germans were not on board with
Hitler's program,
but they thought everybody else was and
there's punishment for descent.
So you get the spread of these toxic
ideas.
When actually most people,
like most college students,
will it privately say I'm against binge
drinking,
I don't want to do it,
but,
but they,
but they think but,
but I know all my friends are into it so
I do it,
but everyone says that that's what I'm
more concerned about.
So I want to know about your experience
on college campuses
because I find when I go there and I'm
usually invited by,
it's usually libertarian groups are
saying in a center,
right or something.
Right now it's College Republicans and
I,
as I always say,
I would gladly do it if the Democrats
would invite me and I'll get the same
exact speech.
Um,
but what I find is that even for
Libertarians who basically just want to
live and let live,
they're finding they're afraid to say
what they think.
So it's not that all of the kids are
screaming and doing violence,
but I'm more concerned about that
secondary set of students that at
college is afraid to say what they think
because you're not going to get out and
suddenly start telling the world that
you think.
This is a great irony though,
because for the Libertarians,
the,
I think you need strong leadership.
Yeah,
no,
they were doing could do a hell of a lot
better in that department.
Like even for the campus.
I think somebody,
you know,
like I,
um,
I,
I so agree with you Michael.
I think that it's,
um,
this is a positive thing.
I think.
And again it's both sides,
you know,
um,
and it's,
it's the loudest voices and then there's
a lot of bullying and shaming and I've
talked to so many students one on one or
even like even in my own classroom I'm,
I'm pretty well known for having one of
the most diverse,
actually maybe the most diverse class,
but not just ethnically and racially,
although that too,
but I had 15 members of the federalist
society,
you know,
in addition to 15 members of the black
students association and Non Muslim
Americans.
And admittedly it wasn't constitutional
law.
It was,
it was a class that was a little bit,
not as charged now,
but I still talk about democracy and an
ethnic conflict and all these issues.
The 2016 election.
But I set the rules,
you know,
like,
I just said these are the rules for this
class and you there's,
there was a wait list so don't come if
you can't do this.
But if somebody for this particular
conversation,
I know it's going to be difficult,
but if somebody says something and they
don't quite use the vocabulary that you
would use or they say something that
maybe offense you for this,
just this class,
I'll say,
can you just not assume worst motives?
Just assume that they just.
Can we just add,
I,
I can have success with it now.
It's not easy.
And I've seen like,
you know,
even our dean said these are free speech
norms.
You can protest,
anybody can protest,
but you can't.
They have to be allowed to speak.
So I think leadership,
I think there's been a lot of cowardice
for this.
So you're selling me on in this instance
on a ton of top down version of this
that you think it has.
I basically,
especially at a college campus,
I do agree with it because you can't,
for lack of a better phrase,
you can't have the inmates running the
asylum.
These kids are supposed to learn there
and there have to learn by people that
are smarter than them.
So in this case,
I am okay with some top down.
Yeah.
I,
I think,
um,
have you had any pushback against that
though?
Because I'd imagine that's got to be
hard pill to swallow.
Not the Dean our Dean has.
Yes.
And if they're always hard cases,
they're hard cases and um,
uh,
I've do,
you know,
yeah,
I get in trouble all the time,
but,
but I not terrible trouble,
you know,
I think maybe it's because I'm a
minority woman to uh,
not everybody is going to be
you using identity politics against a
very clever.
I don't even get used it.
I just like,
you know,
um,
and I definitely know what it feels like
to be an outsider of your first
question.
You know,
I'm,
I,
I've always had a lot of classical
liberals try to speak for me.
So,
uh,
so I,
I really kind of get it.
Um,
but,
uh,
yeah.
Anyway,
well you identify as a minority woman,
don't you?
I've been feeling that more and more.
Yeah.
So,
um,
the other thing about reading your book
though was how,
um,
our state department did not seem to get
these,
these tribal conflicts in Vietnam,
Afghanistan,
Iraq,
does no one call a professor at Yale and
go,
hey,
we're thinking about this is our
strategy.
What do you think?
So when,
when I was reading that,
I kept thinking of,
do you remember during the 2008
election,
so Obama running the first time during
the primaries there having the debate,
the democratic debate,
and Joe Biden was still running at the
time and they're all talking about Iraq
and Joe Biden goes,
you know what,
actually,
Iraq should be split into three
countries because there should be a
Sunni country and a Shia country and a
Kurdish country.
And because this,
this tribal stuff has been going on way
before us,
way before the bread from the Ottomans
and blah,
blah,
blah.
And people thought he was completely
bananas.
Now I think there's probably plenty of
other reasons I think he's been at it,
but putting that aside,
he was getting to the heart of what you
were saying.
Yeah.
And I don't know if that was the right
solution,
but yes,
absolutely.
And you know,
this is interesting.
This half the book is about our foreign
policy fiascos and how it's our us
blindness to these.
Again,
these,
the force of identities that we barely
know anything about Sunni Shias current
kind of the same or,
or Afghanistan,
Pashtuns,
Uzbeks,
whatever,
you know,
um,
Vietnam,
Chinese,
Vietnamese,
Korean,
all the same.
Um,
and it's amazing.
It is something that I have not gotten
in trouble for this because it's a lot
of very critical chapter saying that our
greatest foreign policy disaster stem
from this one thing,
our failure to see that,
that there,
there's this,
this,
these tribal identities that um,
uh,
we imagined that democracy will just
smooth and away,
but just have some elections and
everything will just kind of melt away
or markets.
And what I show is that democracy under
a lot of circumstances actually
catalyzes those group conflicts.
It gets worse.
Are there moments though that for
whatever reason,
either because of war or famine or
something else that actually we can get
past those things.
So like for example,
things actually were going pretty well
in Iraq after they had their elections,
um,
you know,
at,
toward the end of the George W Bush for
getting,
whether we should have gotten in there
or anything like that,
but they were actually having free and
fair elections.
It sounded like he was getting a little
more secularized then we left and okay,
so be it.
But then things got reversed,
but we actually built out of the chaos.
We started doing something good and now,
now,
yeah,
I,
I tell a slightly more detailed story
than that slight disagreement.
I think we are really messed up the
democracy bit when we first got in
there.
And I think actually most of the key
players say that now,
you know,
like secretary of state,
Condoleezza Rice said,
you know,
we should've paid more attention to the
tribal structures.
Um,
and worked with that.
What you're getting at is I write about
a success case and this is the 2007
search.
Again,
putting aside politics that's gotten so
polarized,
but most Americans,
they even know about it,
know that we put it in more troops.
What they don't know is that it was a
180 degree change in our foreign policy.
The people in charge said,
let's pay attention to the groups now
let's go talk to some sheets,
and she used to,
and by the way,
they educated their troops like here's
the difference between them.
Here's what they were,
here's what they eat,
your their ceremonies,
and they really turned it around it and
I document all the numbers within at a
point when things were so bad,
they brought sectarian violence down.
They brought suicide bombing casualties
down,
and then yes,
at that point us lost its political
wealth.
We've left
politics really just straight up mess it
up,
right?
Because things were getting better.
They had real life
is it shows that if we do,
again,
the weird optimist in me,
I think that we have done so many things
in our foreign policy so foolishly that
we can really do so much better.
We just have to pay a little bit of
attention to these groups,
which are what people raised it,
it,
that that's the first thing they hear
about.
Um,
and by the way,
the reason for this is something also I
think positive.
Well,
why are we so blind to it?
Because I contrast us to the British,
the British,
and they're divided in rule.
Um,
they were incredibly group conscious.
They had these huge documents detailing
all the different caste differences and
they used it to divide.
I mean,
they,
you know,
that's not what we should do the
opposite,
but I think it has to do with our own
extraordinary success with assimilation.
You know,
we have an,
of course,
not every group but more than any other
country we,
you know,
the idea is if Irish people and Italians
and Hungarians and Polish can all become
Americans within one generation,
let's have some election because
Sudanese and she isn't currently and
it's,
it's other countries are not like us.
Yeah.
So if,
let's say,
if there is a movement building right
now and some of these enlightenment
values are coming back,
there is,
there is.
I'm with Ya.
All right,
so let's say there is a movement
building.
What do we have to do as people that are
part of it or want to build something
good to avoid the negative parts of
tribalism that will inherently come
along with it.
Well read,
read Amy's.
It ends positively about,
here's some of the things we could do.
I mean just,
I call this the Indu who effect from
that Jack Nicholson's film about Schmidt
where he told us he adopts a child
watching late night TV.
You know,
if you give $15 a month,
this will help little Enugu and they
show a picture of indiegogo.
Now,
as we know from studies that if you show
a picture of 10,000
starving kids in Kenya,
people give a dollar.
If you show a little indigo,
you're willing to give you 100 times
more than that,
so it's tricking the brain into thinking
little Hindu who is an honorary member
of my tribe and so that kind of we know
how to do that from fundraising and so
on.
That has to be applied.
I think politically that you know you
have to identify with these people.
As you pointed out.
You know actually when you actually know
a gay person or a black person or a Jew
or somebody like this,
that's not your normal tribe.
That does break down those tribal
barriers.
Your colleague Paul Bloom and his book
against empathy points out that the dark
side of empathy.
If we're,
if we're super cooperative
and supportive of our tribe,
that makes us even more wary of other
tribes because they can be a threat to
our people that we liked so much and so
we have to break through that.
Acknowledged the tribalism,
but also counter.
It comes back to your favorite work
individually because those studies that
are really positive at the end show that
if you can pull people out of their
groups and by the way not just dumped
them altogether to more hating of each
other,
but if you can interact with another
person as an individual,
which of course is the whole hard part,
it's astounding how much progress you
can make.
The best example I like is the
integration of them,
US military in the 19 fifties,
everybody was against it.
So it was like 80 percent and this can't
work.
And afterwards they found that the
integrated troops were as,
or more effective than the all white
troops.
And then they interviewed everybody and
it was just kind of your point.
They were like,
you know,
if you're in a foxhole,
you,
if you miss your family and the same way
you have to put your life in somebody
else's hand,
you don't care what their accent is or
you don't care what the color of their
skin is.
And that was like an actually an
incredible,
uh,
cross pollinating moment.
Alright,
so let's shift a little bit here for
the,
for the last little bit here.
So I want to talk about some tiger moms
stuff because I do think that partly
what I'm seeing right now is I'm on tour
with Jordan Peterson,
is not that he's Tiger Dad,
but he's filling a role of something
like that.
So it's not necessarily as outright
aggressive as say tiger mom would be,
um,
but he's fit.
He's filling some role there.
Do you think that's sort of fair to say?
So funny that you said that because
obviously it's an incredibly polarizing
figure,
but when I watched a few things and read
a few chips,
that's what it reminded me of.
You don't,
it's kind of,
you know,
one of the things I said in target mom
was assume strength rather than weakness
in your children.
Um,
and I got a lot of trouble for saying
that,
but what's the pushback on a statement
like that?
Like a,
Oh gosh,
you know,
all these mental health issues that I've
gotten a lot of trouble with Jeff.
It's a first of all,
um,
what is tiger parenting?
Right?
I mean,
and it is really true that a lot of
Asian Americans have parents that are
too stifling and too strict on both
sides and they make their children
miserable and people have committed.
So I mean,
it's trust.
It's a parenting is one of those things
that affects everybody because not
everybody has a child,
but everybody had a parent.
So it's always personal.
But I think there is something,
um,
because I,
you know,
I was,
I didn't understand why I was in the
middle of this firestorm either.
Um,
and it's,
it's interesting because you're in this
moment,
you're experiencing it and people would
ask me at the time and at the time I had
no idea at the time I was just trying to
defend myself.
I was stumped.
Somebody told me to stop apologizing,
you know,
that I just kept saying I didn't,
I was supposed to.
It's just a memoir and you're
misunderstanding.
And finally I just decided to own it.
Okay.
I,
it is just a memoir that's true,
but I'm a proud strict mom and then
things got a little bit better.
But I think somebody,
one person said,
you know,
amy,
I think that if the book had been about
like a strict Italian mom or strict
Romanian bomb,
nobody would have cared.
It was at that moment that I hit fear of
parenting and fear of China at the exact
same moment because that was when all
these,
those test scores came out and the US
this great superpowers,
like at number 30,
eight,
China,
Singapore,
and they were all like one,
two,
three,
and it was going to,
they're going to eat our lunch.
Um,
and,
and I think also
Greek tiger mom would have been more
okay.
It's,
but going to your point,
I think it did fill.
People said it touched a nerve.
It's often where there's something
missing already.
Like people need something.
There's a vacuum,
something's off,
the pendulum has swung too far.
Um,
and then you,
this random thing comes in,
fills a void.
So I think it could be a slightly
similar phenomenon.
A quit apologizing in a way that's what
Jordan is saying on some level.
Quit apologizing.
Just be who you are,
set the rules and have goals.
And don't apologize for it.
And there's a lot of people going,
yeah,
okay,
I'm going to,
I'm going to be successful and I'm not
gonna apologize for it.
Yeah,
that's right.
You shouldn't have to do that.
What do we do about that set of people
though?
That is just looking to take everybody
down because I that that's part of the
overcorrection crew,
but they're not going to just go one.
They don't want to.
Restorative justice.
Social justice is not restorative
justice.
It's the Old Testament.
Retributive justice lives must be
destroyed.
You know,
you have to go down and grovel and then
we're going to destroy you.
Yeah.
Well that's why our friend people goes
and he calls it a this he calls this
social justice thing or this idea of a
secular religion.
Yeah,
it is.
That's what I believe it is.
Yeah,
that's right.
Original sin,
your,
your white male,
whatever.
And there is no.
There is no restorative justice.
You just have to be destroyed.
So what can we do?
It's,
it's a hard solution.
Push back and just say,
no,
I'm not gonna.
I'm not gonna apologize.
Uh,
you know,
if I do something wrong I will
apologize,
but I'm not gonna apologize for
something I didn't do or who I am.
I'm a white male.
I,
why should I apologize for that very
quickly.
When you made the decision not to
apologize anymore to stand up for
yourself,
how quickly did it all kind of stopped?
Because I think that's what a lot of
people that are watching this are
wondering.
They're afraid to say anything because
they don't want to just get caught in
that meat grinder.
So I want to show them instances of,
because every one of us that has stood
up and said,
we're here,
we're not just going to bow to you.
We've made it eventually.
I'm not
a huge fan of this.
I'm not exactly sure what these
apologies accomplish.
I think in a way I,
again,
I,
I see things through a tribal leds,
right?
I think that's like a,
like a,
it's a victory.
It's a point.
It's like,
trophy,
I got an apology.
I'm going to extract this.
Um,
it,
um,
it was more of myself to,
uh,
to,
to just kind of say,
wait a second,
I've made a lot of mistakes if you
actually read the book,
who realize it's about my younger
daughter rebelling and it's funny and
there whatever,
unreliable narrators,
but you want.
I'm actually pretty proud.
I'm pretty proud.
Standby everything.
And um,
yeah,
I,
I think it's hugely empowered,
hugely empowering psychologically.
Um,
but you know,
to play devil's advocate on the bigger
picture,
I think we all need to elevate ourselves
because I'm sort of in a different camp
than you guys.
Like I'm looking at the country inn
where and as the optimist,
I feel like we all.
And I,
that's why I admired Michael so much.
Like it's hard to recognize yourself as
being somebody that's being tribal or
whatever the US versus them always.
And what I have noticed because this
happened to me is one bad thing happens
to you because we've all had this some
just terrible attack,
very cruel thing,
incredibly unfair.
And it's human nature.
I get so angry at the other side,
right?
And rightfully so.
I think the warning I would have is how
many people do put in the them category.
I think we should all narrow that,
make it smaller,
you know,
because there are these big labels and
people do it on all sides and I even do
it.
I just get so mad at this massive pool
of people that I think of as my enemies
because something horrible just happened
to me,
you know,
it was something incredibly insulting or
this terrible stuff that I get on
twitter.
I mean,
we all get the hate.
Um,
and it's so easy just to hate back I
think.
I think that's the hard thing.
So actually I think he narrowed the
enemy.
Yeah,
for sure.
I mean,
if you listen to conservative talk
radio,
oh my gosh,
it's just so polarized.
I mean,
every other word is,
you know,
the liberals,
the left,
the Lib,
tards yards,
uh,
you know,
the New York slimes,
the Washington composed,
that's pretty quickly.
My wife calls him the screamer.
She's Germany's,
are these people in the radio screaming?
It's like,
that's what gets ratings.
Apparently they're just as bad as the
people on the left.
India,
we,
yeah,
we have to stop doing this,
that the principle of charity just be
charitable to the person you're talking
to.
You don't assume you know,
because they slipped up and used this
word instead of that word.
Therefore they're Hitler.
No more reductive ad hilarity.
You have to stop that.
So do you think it's possible to wrap
this up on a nice boat and use a little
of our optimism here and a little of you
or moral arc here that the exhaustion
with all of this,
enough of these conversations that
actually clearly are breaking into the
mainstream at the moment and all of that
will lead to a sort of political
realignment where it seems to me that I
would argue at this point we basically
needed trump even though I didn't vote
for him,
we needed him for this now for years of
just upheaval and fertile ground and
ideas and people realigning their
thinking and strange alliances and all
that.
But that what we can get.
We don't need another trump after.
I don't think if,
if everything actually goes okay,
we will actually be okay with something
decent again,
but we needed the thing to be shook up
before we could get there.
Yeah.
I'm an optimist for the say I,
I think,
um,
and it's very hard to say people are so
angry.
So there was,
it's also possible that it's completely
the other way.
For sure.
Yeah.
You know,
it's funny.
I'm also,
we started with the masterpiece cake
thing and I said I'm not a college
professor,
but I,
I've been giving talks a lot of places.
And the question is,
is there another,
is there a model?
Is there a country that you've studied
that could be the model for us to get
out of our political tribalism?
And actually this is actually could even
get me in trouble because it's.
No,
no,
but I just say we're the model.
We are the bottle we.
And it's not that we're per,
oh my gosh,
you know,
we have made so many mistakes that we're
in a very bad moment in many ways,
but we have the apparatus,
we have something special.
This thing of that I call the super good
context,
um,
our constitution,
of course we have repeatedly failed to
live up to those ideals,
but the ideals are there and this is an
ethnically and religiously neutral
document.
Again,
not the way it's played out in reality
is always the,
our ideals have always exceeded our
reality.
So it's an aspirational country.
It's an aspirational document and this
is why we come full circle,
you know,
I think we're worthy.
Enlightenment experiment.
Yeah.
I never thought,
and this is where maybe I was not
somebody that you remember in the late
nineties when the Berlin Wall came down,
it was like,
we're going to be one world,
maybe Saudi Arabia and Turkey will join
the EU.
That navy,
the United States will join the EU.
I was always like,
never too big.
So I'm still a little bit of a tribalist
I think that I think the world at this
point is too big a unit.
Yeah.
Well you use figuring out that for
countries that are in Europe.
So.
Right about.
Yeah.
But I'm really glad that that'll be a
good place to wrap this,
um,
that you mentioned he's aspirational
documents because as you guys can see
through our window,
right in there in our control room,
we've got an American flag in there,
but also what you can see,
maybe you can see it.
Amy's,
I just got these two huge print giant
print of the declaration of independence
and a giant print of the constitution
that I was given at a,
at a speaking thing that I did for three
turning point.
And yes,
we haven't always lived up to those
things,
but if we could get back to that,
that's why I care about these things.
I'm always tweeting about these things
and when I'm in D,
c,
I go and I take pictures of all these
things and put up,
oh,
this is what Thomas Jefferson said,
that they've given us the blueprint.
It doesn't mean that they were perfect.
It doesn't mean that we've always done
it right.
But this idea that someone do it better
than us for as bad as it may seem,
we're not killing each other in the
streets right now.
Yes,
there is.
They're unjust murder.
Yes.
Is there just this or that,
but it's still pretty damn good.
If we were going to bring it home
schermer well,
I mentioned being a multiplanetary
species when we call an Eis Mars
and we're going to do it.
You know what?
We got to set up some kind of
government,
some kind of economic system.
What?
What documents would you bring?
Yeah,
the declaration of independence and the
constitution that that would be the
place to start.
Maybe they'll tweak it and experiment
and then it'll get a little bit better
or worse,
and then we can look at that as an
experiment and go,
okay,
here's what we should do here,
but that also,
that perspective also gives us that
Sagan esque Pale blue dot look back at
the earth and go,
oh,
there are no borders from Mars is just
this blue dot and maybe that'll change
our perspective.
A little bit about the tribal nature of
our species.
That's actually a great idea.
Maybe my new argument when people are
telling me how horrible America is,
it's like,
you know what,
if we were on a Mars tomorrow,
we're going somewhere tomorrow.
You got a better document that to start
us off with and I'm pretty sure nobody
would have something better.
No,
you know,
they probably wouldn't know what to say,
but that would be.
That'd be great.
I know you could do something to finish
this up strong.
That will bring us into the future and
into outer space and all that.
Well guys,
this has been,
I mean this hour.
You by.
This has been a pleasure.
I am A.
I am demanding that you come back for a
one on one and shermer.
I'll do this one more time.
It's been a pleasure guys,
and we're going to link to a Michael and
amy's websites and books and all that
good stuff right now below.